frente al vesubio periferia napolitana
al sur de italia
[Música]
kiko habitan la pobreza y la
criminalidad organizada este barrio es
uno de los fraudes de la camorra la
mafia napolitana
para arrancarle la juventud a la
ilegalidad esta fundación financiada en
parte por la alcaldía de nápoles lucha
diariamente ante los más jóvenes
gabriel expósito
34 el intenso y se dejan le recibimos
jóvenes hasta los 16 años es una lucha
diaria porque desafortunadamente en este
barrio ópera la micro criminalidad y hay
otros problemas y estos jóvenes no
merecen eso cada semana 120 niños son
acogidos aquí para actividades
extracurriculares un bastión de la
legalidad en el corazón de un proyecto
medioambiental inédito mientras los
jóvenes hacen actividades en el piso en
el techo de la fundación acaban de poner
en marcha una curiosa instalación
esta mañana los técnicos vienen a hacer
un control de rutina 166 paneles
fotovoltaicos fueron instalados aquí
en cuanto a la energía fósil la energía
producida aquí gracias al sol hace
ahorrar 30 toneladas anuales de co2 es
como si hubiésemos sembrado 140 árboles
en la instalación tiene garantía de 25
años permite igualmente conservar
eventuales excedentes de energía
inutilizados ruiz soy por camps revertir
sistema había cubo mire este es el
sistema de acumulación durante el día
producimos energía y la que no es
consumida de inmediato queda almacenada
aquí ello permite usarla en la noche
dentro de poco la instalación será
conectada a la red eléctrica de la
ciudad para ser distribuida en la zona
40 familias desfavorecidas del barrio
podrán entonces recibir esta energía
limpia entre ellas la tratan de derrita
a la que le reembolsaran cada año entre
200 y 300 euros del costo de sus
facturas de electricidad que no podremos
prender el ipduv pero no será gastar aún
parviz carpenter esto nos permitirá
adquirir otros bienes tal vez comprar
nuevos pares de zapatos para los niños
desde que mi esposo tuvo un impacto ya
no tenemos ingreso fijo entonces se
trata de una ayuda muy valiosa
si la iniciativa prevé igualmente una
acción pedagógica ante las familias
la asociación que inició este proyecto
de comunidad energética nos aconseja
sobre buenas prácticas para reducir el
consumo cuántos son en casa 5 cuántas
veces lavar la ropa diariamente 4 ó 5
mezclamos la lavandería de la vasta
villa tiene un cargo ahora la lavadora
debe estar totalmente llena y ya no
podrás lavar en la noche
porque con la energía solar nuestro
objetivo es hacerlo durante el día para
aprovechar el sol un ejemplo concreto de
transición ecológica que también tiene
que ver con la formación de los más
jóvenes
cada semana los jóvenes de la fundación
participan en laboratorios y talleres
para conocer mejor los beneficios de la
energía renovable y ahora son los
jóvenes los que instruyen a sus padres
cuando olvidan clasificar sus basuras
tal como les enseñamos aquí entonces las
madres me llaman y me dicen no téngase
ahora quieren que hagamos las cosas así
también en casa para mí es una
satisfacción porque ese es el trabajo de
conexión entre generaciones de este
modelo de producción autónoma de energía
renovable asociado a actividades
sociales es una innovación en esta
región en italia otras once comunidades
energéticas han surgido la idea está
empezando a inspirar en otros lugares de
la península todo el día recibimos
llamadas de otros lugares desde el frío
en el norte o desde sicilia en el sur
todos quieren ser orientados porque
a lanzar proyectos de este tipo nos
volvimos un laboratorio a escala real
para toda italia un laboratorio de la
ecología del futuro que hace converger
protección del medio ambiente y lucha
contra las desigualdades sociales en
italia